the beefcake hack is finally back
and for this i applaud and shout thank
you god
yes it's true roll the nexio
he's back
all right yeah
chris cuomo announced he's accepted an
anchor job at news nation during an
interview on the network tuesday night i
guess matt lauer wasn't available
we went to a news nation viewer for
comment
[Applause]
so good
true like adam schiff's heartbeat i
didn't know news nation existed
cuomo made the announcement on dan
abrams live on his tiny tiny network but
cuomo insisted he actually like that
network was so small
i had decided that i can't go back uh to
what people see as the big game
i don't think i can make a difference
there
i think we need insurgent media i think
we need outlets that aren't fringe and
just trying to fill their pockets
ah he decided right sounds like what i
said about the prom
i didn't want to go with you anyway i
don't even like you and that wasn't me
you spray-painted your car
of course there are no reports of any
major network actually having offered
cuomo a job but that's probably just
because he never picked up the phone he
was too busy volunteering for the fire
department in the hamptons
you know you don't hear ball players
bragging about getting sent to the
miners although at cnn getting sent to
the miners it means something else
[Laughter]
dark tonight yeah
bad that was bad in the interview cuomo
insisted that people could trust the
work he would do on the network
i'm going to try very hard to be fair
[Laughter]
that's less convincing than a
door-to-door butt implant salesman
but maybe we could see more classics
like this
the turnout of white supremacists was
thankfully pathetic which is why i
didn't have to go there and cover it
this is this is a travis a mockery a
travesty of a sham of a mockery let's
get after what do you say let's get
after it let's get after it let's get
after it it's a big night what do you
say
let's get after it
in any case if chris can make this kind
of cable news come back there's
definitely hope for his brother to make
a similar one
look for him on core tv as an analyst or
a defendant
cat do you uh do you believe that he
actually likes that the network is small
i mean like
nobody believes that which is why i
don't know why he like he just can't
help himself he's like you may think
that i got demoted because of my
multi-faceted scandal that
involved both my journalistic integrity
and sexual harassment whatever
misconduct but i actually like it and
the reason i like it is because i can
better help you yes
i can do the work more to help you i i
like but the thing is with this guy when
he thought about that he's like oh this
is good yeah this is good
this is going to make this not
embarrassing for me that obviously is
this is like you can't read people's
minds but you can read his yes you know
exactly he's like oh i'm how do i look
right now i look really good this is
this point about being insurgent media
tyrus you know how happy i am about this
right yeah i called you at 4 am when i
found out
[Laughter]
he's back i was like the bad man under
your bed
you know i couldn't sleep no you're not
going to sleep for probably months i
think i'm i'm a little concerned guppy i
think he's going to let you down yeah
you saw him i know try to keep it
straight
give the news to the 17 people that are
watching
it's a little discouraging because the
entire
push of news nation was we're just gonna
do news right we don't care about
ratings we carry this is a neutral place
where we just report the news they even
promised to make breaking news breaking
news again
and then they broke news with this
this dude he is like every guy whose
wife left him for a younger guy and got
everything and he's in his studio
apartment and his kids reluctantly have
to visit him and he's like this is such
a great start for me
like i'm so excited i got my bus pass
you know like i'm three blocks away from
the ymca
like this is you guys are gonna look
kids stop crying no you can't go home
i'd call your mother but she got my cell
phone this is literally but he's trying
to make a great situation out of it's
over you realized you realize that jamie
lissau is watching yes no
he didn't get an apartment
guy um i love the fact that he sees
himself as a rebel this is gonna be
insurgent media right we're just fringe
you know those giant networks they're
fringe
the son and governor
son and brother of a governor is the
ultimate underdog tale right that's uh
the chris cuomo story you're the one
person in america clamoring for his
comeback i was from the beginning it's
you yes i was behind this from the
beginning
i actually had a whole monologue begging
cnn to not fire him i didn't i did you
want him now he's just
i want to be here
at fox
on the 5. oh no he this
this network is
far too big for his taste
as he tells us but i actually disagree i
take him in his word that he likes
working at a small network because he
seemed to enjoy it at cnn
[Laughter]
that was really mean
[Laughter]
i like it uh dean first of all how do we
find this station
honestly tyrus knew so much about it i
was shocked guys never heard of it hey i
heard about it today
i was like what is he where is he going
i keep looking going news news nation
i hadn't i've never heard about it until
this right here and i'm and i'm probably
not going to ever hear about it again
unless i watch your show when you make
fun of him but now you have material for
the next six months the only way i'm
going to be able to find the material is
if i find the station and i'm not going
to do that but i'm going to have to rely
on somebody else to like look for the
look for the little bits and pieces
you've got three producers assigned to
that right now exactly already you're
gonna hire someone to watch a news
nation all day yeah
it'll probably be their ceo
anyway i want to thank dan i think it's
dan abrams right that was dan abrams
yeah that was the guy who's in charge of
this thing so thank you dan we owe you
one
almost makes up for that crappy website
meteorite
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else